When the 2018 iPad Pro was released, the most
disappointing thing about it was the software.
But today, Apple has announced iPadOS, a new
operating system that allows iPads to be more
like computers.
It’s coming this September, and it supports
every iPad since the iPad Air 2.
Let’s get right into the changes.
First of all, there’s a new home screen
that holds 6 columns of apps instead of 5
currenty on iOS 12, and they can all slide
over to the side to make room for the new
Today View with customizable widgets, all
on one page.
iOS 13’s new Dark Mode is also coming to
iPadOS.
It turns on easily from the control center
and it works systemwide.
Apple’s also making it super easy for third-party
apps to support it with their new SwitchUI
framework.
Face ID on the iPad Pro will unlock up to
30% faster, and apps will be smaller in size
so they’ll download faster and launch up
to 2x faster than before.
The Photos app gets a new Photos tab, which
organizes your photos in new day, month and
year views.
We also finally have some awesome photo editing
tools, allowing you to adjust things like
brightness, contrast, saturation, and white
balance.
You get those same tools for video editing
as well, alongside auto enhance, crop and
rotate.
Yes, you can finally rotate videos.
With iPadOS, Safari automatically chooses
the desktop version of websites and it automatically
optimizes it for touch.
There’s also a brand new download manager
that saves downloads right into the new Downloads
Folder within the Files app, making it much
more like an actual computer.
And speaking of the Files app, it’s now
actually decent and more computer-like than
ever before by FINALLY allowing you to connect
an external hard drive, SD Card or USB flash
drive and transfer files.
The biggest deal is the new On My iPad location
which allows you to create folders and transfer
files directly to those folders without having
to first import them to camera roll or put
them on the iCloud drive, so it’s basically
like a MacOS file manager.
You can even zip and unzip files and folders.
Another big step up is that you can now connect
a digital camera and import files directly
into apps like Lightroom, without having to
copy them to camera roll first like we had
to before.
For cloud storage, you can now share files
and entire folders with other people, and
we even get support for Shared servers, so
if you have a cloud-accessible NAS, you can
access those files on your iPad.
And finally, there’s a new column view that
makes it easy to navigate through folders,
and a preview pane that gives you detailed
metadata with quick actions like markup, rotate
and create PDF.
Apple has also taken the iPad a step further
by adding the same keyboard shortcuts we get
on MacOS, right onto the iPad using the smart
keyboard or any compatible Bluetooth keyboard.
You can now also download custom fonts right
from the app store and manage them on the
iPad.
The most annoying thing to do while browsing
the web is creating new accounts and passwords,
well now Apple is adding a new Sign in with
Apple feature that automatically and instantly
creates accounts using your existing Apple
ID with a simple Face ID or Touch ID confirmation.
And there’s even an option to create a unique
fake email address that forwards to your real
email, so it adds tons security as well.
The iPad can also be used to encrypt your
HomeKit Security video cameras footage so
you know that no one else is able to hack
in and view your cameras feed
Apple has also completely redesigned the text
editing, with brand new gestures that are
so much easier to understand and use.
To move the cursor while, editing, just touch
and drag it to your desired location.
To select a block of text, just drag your
finger over it.
You can also select text using multiple taps.
Two taps for a word.
Three for a sentence, and four taps for an
entire paragraph.
Once selected, pinch with three fingers to
copy, then spread with three fingers to paste.
And there’s no more need to shake your iPad
to undo, now simply swipe with three fingers
instead.
Apple has also added no on-screen keyboard
features, like the new Quickpath, or swipe,
keyboard, and the ability to pink and shrink
the keyboard to detach it and move it wherever
you want for one-handed typing.
Now onto multitasking, Apple has added some
additional options to easily switch between
the app that’s open in slide over mode.
Simply swipe up on the bar on the bottom of
the app and every previous app you’ve had
open pops up.
You can even slide along the bar to swipe
between slide over apps, just like you can
do on the home bar for full-screen apps.
Another huge update that makes the iPad more
like a Mac is the ability to open multiple
windows of the same app, so that means two
Notes apps, two mail apps, or even two third-party
apps like Microsoft word, side by side.
This also means that you can have multiple
split-screen spaces open with multiple instances
of the same apps running at the same time.
And to view those spaces, just tap on an app
on the dock and it’ll show you all of the
spaces that include that app.
Apple has also made it easier to work with
the Apple Pencil, with a new easy way to markup
a photo or page.
Just drag your apple pencil from the corner
of the screen to mark up.
And there’s also an awesome new Full Page
option which actually includes the whole full-length
page you’re viewing, not just the section
that was visible when you started the markup.
Within markup, there’s a new pencil tool
pallete with updated icons.
You can easily shrink or drag and move the
palette anywhere you’d like so it doesn’t
get in your way.
Now here’s an outstanding new feature called
sidecar.
You can now use your iPad as a second Mac
display, allowing you to view an app on the
iPad while working on your Mac, or exactly
the opposite.
You can actually use your iPad to draw, design,
edit or create content using Full desktop
Mac apps while viewing the finished result
on your Mac.
And it even works wirelessly.
Alongside all of those awesome changes to
the iPad, Apple has a massive list of changes
that are coming with iPadOS, and I’ll share
that link in the video description below.
But here are some of the coolest changes.
The iPad now supports the PS4 and Xbox One
S gaming controller.
The 2018 iPad Pro now supports Dolby Atmos
playback.
You can now select WiFi networks and Bluetooth
accessories straight from the control center.
You can now add attachments to events in Calendar.
Maps is completely redesigned to include more
detail.
Siri has a brand new voice.
You can now control your entire iPad using
a new voice control feature.
And there’s just so much more than that,
so if this video helped you out, make sure
to tap like and click that button above to
subscribe.
Thanks for watching, and we’ll see you in
the next video!